il n'y aura que 100 places disponibles
dans les bassins pour des créneaux de
deux heures le centre aquatique du lac a
revu toute son organisation et à
installer un protocole strict pour
l'entrée nous mettons à disposition
cette zone là de cabine
on voit au sol le marquage pour
respecter la distance le cabinet après
avoir désinfecté la cabine qui viendra
d'être utilisés permettra au nouvel
usager d'y accéder la personne se change
on la retrouve de l'autre côté pour
accueillir les nageurs des cabinets ont
été mis à disposition pour les guider
jusqu'au vestiaire
une fois changé ils sont ensuite emmenés
jusqu'aux douche et au bassin les gens
qui pourront venir devront au préalable
s'inscrire donc nous avons dû aussi
mettre en place sur le site internet
le gris d'inscription qui leur permet de
devenir
et puis nous avons privilégié évidemment
le
le passage des personnes de montigny et
de voisins qui sont les deux co
propriétaire de l'établissement pour une
ligne d'eau il faudra compter six
nageurs maximum le bonnet de bain qui
est obligatoire doit être
systématiquement plonger dans du
désinfectant avant d'être utilisées et
les serviettes doivent être placés dans
les gradins à des endroits précis de
tout temps même en dehors de l'aco vide
l'eau est désinfectée ni désinfectante
nous avons fait le choix de que ce soit
par le chlore est donc en l'occurrence à
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune étude qui
pourrait démontrer qu'il y aurait des
risques potentiels à pratiquer la
natation dans un espace aquatique et
ludique comme celui ci la piscine
accueillera donc jeudi 25 juin les
nageurs
quant aux salles de fitness et de
musculation de l'espace forme du centre
elles rouvriront à partir du lundi 29
juin